[Music]
all right welcome to IO 257 accelerating
or computing Tennessee workload at were
application on kubernetes engine my name
is Yoshi I'm a product manager at Google
looking into kubernetes mostly working
on GPU TPU and also multi-tenancy every
wish I've been working at Google and
various things borg and then recently
cumulus for the last year or a year and
a half have been focusing primarily on
like getting machine learning up and
going but Curtis I also like trying to
hopefully extend that to like other more
compute intensive workloads oh so let's
say I get started will cover two hot
topics in the computer industry today
one is machine learning and the other is
containers both technologies are kind of
two important pillar critical pillars
for modern computing oops
modern computing you may ask like why
containers for ml are they really a you
know good combination and you know is it
really irrelevant because we know that
the audience but the people who use
container today's are more on the
engineering side and who do the ml as
more data scientist those profiles are
different and we think from our own
experience the answer is yes ml work
clothes can also benefit from containers
just like any other workloads and we're
gonna dig into more about the benefits
throughout this session for those who
know containers kubernetes is something
that what comes together right but for
those who just heard containers it's
like not so intuitive but no worries
we're gonna show the value of kubernetes
and how it works well with containers
very soon just keep somewhere in the
mind that in your mind that kubernetes
will allow your mate you know allow you
to make your machine learning app
patience cloud native so who the world
actually does that you know who actually
use cooking your containers kubernetes
and machine learning like all together
in a sucky its us at Google like like
the keynote I think you know all the
leaders emphasized on akrura nays
machine learning is there definitely
truth that we actually use containers
kubernetes and machining on all together
and we we in case the internal always
called bore and we are basically do you
know bring that experience of deploying
machine learning application in
container through such orchestration
system to open source to everyone
through the open source kubernetes and
that's very exciting thing so let me
highlight the values that we learned
throughout this experience are very
quickly first container should help
improving your productivity by packaged
app you can package up your favorite
tools and frameworks into container
images then you can share them across
the teams to standardize the tools and
frameworks and although perhaps were
closed this will basically allow you to
reuse everything that you know somebody
has created and then prevent reinventing
the wheels which is great for
productivity secondly container will
also help reducing our reproduce
reproducing reliable results this is
very important for data scientists
anyone using the same image with the
same configuration pre-configured and
with the same tools and framers and the
same data technically everyone should be
able to reach you know reproduce very
reliable results instead of you know
someone did in different way and as a
result if you have to figure out time
why that happened it's very
time-consuming but you know through
standardizing using the same thing you
it will give you some sort of
really negating the reproducing the
reliable results third one is
portability you can easily pour your
environment from one to another with
containers we can also take containers
very quickly to the cloud to take
advantage of the unlimited you know huge
resources whenever you need so now we
briefly understand the value you know
how containers are great for machine
learning is that it are you good enough
let's step back for a moment about you
know the world picture the reason that
we're investing machine learning could
be improving you know greater or
providing greater user experience
through machine learning or perhaps
increasing productivity through the
automation that machine an improvised so
the goal here is to in this diagram is
to really get into production from
research and training as quickly as
possible to maximize such investments
for that we need to train of their
models at a large scale and then deploy
the train models continuously and quick
as possible in production for inference
this implies that you know for your
containers which has your machinery
applications we need a infrastructure to
actually get to this point and that's
exactly where crew Rena is come into
play so let's look quickly take I'll
take a look into the values occur Rene's
first is scales kubernetes provides very
scalable infrastructure to process
massive massive number of workloads it
also you can also run kubernetes on a
single workstation and you can also run
it on thousands of nodes in cloud as
well so here it's a really really scales
very well and provides your schedule
infrastructure
Kru Bernays would also help you increase
your productivity what I mean by that is
it will free you up from managing your
own workstation servers even BMS it lets
you just simply focus on your
application and services you know all
the things that you have underneath it
is something that you want to let Crenn
age the handle and lastly your
community's applications are portable
you could pour your workloads to
literally any Korean age deployment
whether it's an on-premise or on pram or
in cloud Karina's provides an open and
standard API and it's portable cross
various products and services really
across banners and that vendor
neutrality or is developed defined
open-source this portability is very
very important for us I mean not only
for us but for the community so let me
quickly wrap up you know the values that
we just described why containers and
Korean is for machine learning with this
sorry with this with this diagram so
basically let's call it it's like a
cloud native machine learning stack you
know nutshell you just choose your
favorite you know machine learning
framework and tools and pack it up into
containers and then run them on
Cabrini's at scale it helps you to be
productive it will pretty helpless
reliable results it will also help you
deploy your application wherever your
life either it's an on-prem or client
cloud it also it also scales from a
single workstation in front of you to
thousands of thousands of nodes in cloud
right I think I kind of talked about the
concept enough and I feel now a little
bit uncomfortable because my background
is more on engineering size so I want to
see something more
and it's probably get you know our hands
dirty to see how that really works what
I've just talked it's not like concept
well I've talked about a concept but
what we're gonna talk about here is like
new features and products with
demonstrations so it's not like
vaporware or concept only thing and I
really you know very excited because
these are really all available to you as
of today and you could literally do
everything with everything we're gonna
show fish is going to show here from
today first we're excited to announce
that mini cube project now supports GPUs
mini q I guess it stands for
mini kubernetes it's a great tool it's a
really really great tool for anyone
who's new to kubernetes you can run mini
cube on your local workstation and as
it's a single no cluster inside a
virtual machine google contributed to
contributed GPU support and mini cube
because it makes the development and
develop and deploy and test workflow
super fast so we're very very excited
that not a mini project supports on GPU
so how can we use it you first need a
workstation and you also need some spare
GPU so if your GPU by someone else you
need to kind of spare some you know the
rest of the GPU so that we can use it
for the mini Q and then we attach it to
the virtual machine we use via virtual
machine here so to use a VM we need to
have that installed there's a timer and
also we use a immu to pass through the
GPUs to the kvn on mini cube I think
there's a automated like a thing going
also wanted to talk to them right and
yeah but that's pretty much it and once
you have that Percocet done you can
start mini cube by putting this - - GPU
into the menu command line we're using
KVM so we put the VM driver there but
that's pretty much it and after that
will you know you will install and video
driver with these two commands and if
you go through this step your your
workstation is running kubernetes
connected to GPU and you're ready to go
so let's really start running a job how
you're gonna do that it's really really
really simple I'm sorry it's really
simple in this example we you all you
have to do is to specify the type of the
you know GP check out the resource you
want to use and the amount of the GPU
that you need so in this particular
example we're requesting two NVIDIA GPUs
from the workstation and that's pretty
much it this is all you have to do to
access to the GPU to the mini Q which
mini Q has in your workstation all right
so Netflix I just went through the quick
example but let's run our first
container which he views on mini coop so
one or two fish come on station just
give me a second as I get logged into my
laptop screen okay
so to start off I just want to highlight
that there is a very detail useful set
up and usage guide for mini cube where
you can go and look up on github so you
don't have like memorize I'll remember
everything to show here and you have
like a really good guide that you can
follow once you go back to your
workstations so hope this is readable by
everyone okay so what I want to show
here is like I want to show that I have
a workstation and I have GPUs attached
to this workstation so if I run okay I
guess I need to connect again just give
me a second this is what happens if you
log out and log back in
and to go through my security okay there
we go
and I need to reset the size if you just
do this again so what I want to show
here is like I have two GPUs on my
workstation I have one running that's
driving my display and so that mini cube
is not going to use that by default and
then I'm gonna have I have a secondary
span GPU which mini cube will pick up
automatically so setting up mini cube is
pretty easy as Yoshi said all you have
to do is like literally just type in
this command that I have free typed here
so I can just say mini cube start but
I'm not going to do that now here
because it's going to take like 30
seconds for it to set up and I have
already pre set it up for you so let's
go look at the status and mini cube says
there's already a VM running here right
so this this mini cube running for those
of you who don't know hiring familiar
with mini cube it's curious that's
really easy to run locally or on your
workstation whether it's on a Mac or are
on Windows or Linux right but in this
case GPUs work primarily on the next
four now so you'll have to like stick to
a Linux force for for running the GPUs
dance
describe your immediate environment yeah
definitely so let me show what the cube
earnest capacity looks like for those of
you who are familiar with cubed is north
capacity what we expect to see here is
we expect to see as part of capacity GPU
showing out so there's already CPUs of
allocated for for my VM and I was
allocated some memory about like 16 gigs
and I also allocated a single GPU right
I didn't have to manually allocate but
then the whole mini cube workflow
automatically picks that out so we have
a mini cube with a GPU attached so next
off our SEP our next part of our demo is
to like actually show an ml training job
and show it to be running on mini cube
locally and then let's see if we can
pull up tens about just show us the jobs
progress
for that what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use a pre can water because the
point of this demo is not to build cool
ml models but rather show how
infrastructure just works seamlessly so
I'm going to use a pre trained or like
pre-built model which is ResNet for
those of you who are familiar with that
I'm using less than 50 specifically in
this case Google tends flow team has
already optimized that quite a bit so
I'm going to reuse the same model and I
have it packaged as part of a continual
image and I have my data set for this
model stored on my workstation so I'm
going to use NFS to map the data set
into my mini qvm and similarly I can map
in my code also from my host right so
those are possibilities that you have
working iteratively on your workstation
so let me go ahead and get to that so I
have I'm going to go ahead and launch so
I'm going to go ahead and launch the job
here so for those of you are curious let
me show you what Java actually launched
I'm pulling it up on github because it's
a little bit more easier to read so how
a container here the Hairston's flow and
the repository and the rest net
repository the latest showed already
prepackaged is full of container and I'm
running I'm running literally the same
instructions that's mentioned on the
official restaurant model right it's the
same set of instructions except that
it's run from a container and it's
declaratively specified as a cumulus
configuration in this configuration you
can take and port it and run it on any
mini cube and you will get the same
results and that's what yoshi was
referring to when he said like
portability and reproducibility so and I
also like tweak some of the parameters
to make sure that it runs reasonably
locally I want to like beat for 10 days
for some one import to run so I want it
to be really fast
so now that's done let's go look at the
job if it's actually running so the job
is already running let's look at its
logs and see if it's showing GPUs so
what we are expecting to see is we're
expecting tensorflow
to show that it's using GPUs so we can
see that here
it's saying that it's sorry it's showing
that it's using a GPU device Quadro a.m.
4000 that happens to be the free GPU on
a workstation and dense flow is like
automatically picking that up and you
didn't have to change much like you know
I really have to change dense flowing
take a pre can model and run it on
cumulus and training is already starting
and if you were to like pull up ten
support for this it would look something
like this so training is happening now
and if you look at the ten support
instance this is from a pre pre trial
run that I did before the demo but
you've seen that if I wait for a day
it'll make some progress of about like
two it box and the the progress rate is
about two images per second so this is
not really for real training but this is
more for fine-tuning and getting your
model working so you can actually like
do it at scale on like really large
machines so that's that's sort of all I
had to say about mini cube Yoshi thanks
fish switchback - yep flights good
alrighty thanks bish
so now we have our first email
application running on mini cube and
it's great and it's using GPU now
luckily we are already saturating the
GPU there and we thought our application
models or I mean heavier than we thought
so what should we do should we buy more
workstations or should we build a data
center or at least plan building on the
data center probably not let's go to
google kubernetes engine because it's
the best place to run Austrian learning
in containers
that's because GPUs in Korea news engine
is now in January generally available
and ready for the enterprise GPUs and
Korean Air's engine allows you to allows
your container to access GPU via
kubernetes api there's no need to manage
your own hardware like workstation
servers or even the empty just consume
the GPUs whenever you need and as much
as you like this flexibility is
something that cloud can provide
and we're also we're excited that our
customers are loving this product as the
GPU core hours since we we introduced a
back since back in 2017 the core hours
has exploded more than 10x and this is
very very exciting for us and whenever
we have this conversation about and
getting feedback about this feature
people are just loving rapport just
loving the the elastic apps as flexible
aspect of accessing GPUs through
kubernetes engine for their containers
we have a wide range of GPUs and
curviness
all at all in all GPUs models available
in computer engine can be also using a
kubernetes engine for example in video v
hundred this is the high end GPU with
top performance for both training and
inference so if you're wondering
training and in France this be hundred
is a perfect choice because it's good at
both P hundred is a well balanced GPU a
good poor performance and the cost is a
lot lower that balance is somebody
something that people like about ka T or
the last but really not the least
because this is indeed the most widely
used GPU as as far as we are aware of
and it's a great for starters so if
you're done with a workstation if you're
wondering which GPU to use KT is
definitely a good kind of starting point
so speaking of reducing cost I didn't
mention in the slide but we also have
interesting feature called preemptable
vm for preemptable GPUs which where you
can access to the CPU with a lot lower
cost the difference is that your GPU
could be evicted with a short notice
which means that if you could cheer to
attune your application to handle like
checkpoint frequently or you know have
somehow handle the robustness part you
can actually achieve very high
performance with very low cost and some
people are very using this wisely for
their bachelor clothes you know if
you're learning a Bosch workload
you know you don't actually use the GPU
all the time so you just quickly ramp up
and quickly round down and preemptable
GPUs are really perfect solution for
that now we know in addition to these
GPUs that are introduced we're very
excited to announce that Nvidia people
is also now available as beta in
coronaries engine p4 is a very unique
GPU which comes with a very fast in
French performance we're going to talk
about inference so we're gonna you know
show that later but with a very very
fast inference performance but you know
the trick you can actually save the cost
significantly so this this GPU is a very
unique one you know if you compare to
the rest of the the GPU models that we
have in our family so we were a great
addition so then let's look into how you
could actually use a GPU synchronous
engine in this example I'm creating a
new pool with GPUs and attaching to a
customer no pool is a very considerable
concept that there's a you know virtual
machines inside a pool and then we
specify a GPU there and you can attach
it to any kubernetes on your cluster
whenever you like we chose this example
because it has it will give you more
flexibility if you wanted to attach you
know to your existing cluster just more
you know flexible if you don't need it
you can actually scale down or no pool
to onto your later data which I will
describe later in this case we're
creating two nodes with one Nvidia the
top high-end performance we hundred on
each node and then attaching to this
pool into an existing cluster and that's
pretty much it for the setup
so now let's consume those GPUs again
that you might realize that this example
is actually the same as the previous one
that we use for a mini queue and you're
right the same spec this one is
requesting to and video GPUs right but
this time instead of requesting that on
a workstation
it's requesting to and video GPUs in the
clock
in the cloud so this will tell I hope
this will tell you that you know
Carini's you know API and also
applications are really really portable
GPUs and Korean engines are really
already flexible and scalable but that's
not it
we also have cluster autoscaler with GPU
and this is really only available on
google kubernetes engine it would
automatically scale up the cluster
whenever needed and down and to hit the
performance you know to hit the best
performance over cost the nose of the
nose where the GPUs will be
automatically created when a cluster may
need more capacity and I think that can
be scaling up is pretty intuitive but
for because GPUs are much more expensive
compared to CPUs the scaling down aspect
kind of resume at least to me very well
so now knows where GPUs also get deleted
when their idle so you don't necessary
have to spin up em you know node with
empty you know empty cycles it will
always be adjusting to your workload so
then how can we access you know you know
use this cool feature it's very simple
and easy all you have to do is to turn
on the autoscaler
you know with a small sample cell with
several flags and I'm using the previous
example here so what I did here is put
this enable - - - enable auto scaling
and put mini specify minimum you know
going down to scale down to minimum to 0
node and scale up to maximum fine notes
so if I need more capacity it will go up
to 5 nodes if I'm idle it will go down
to 0 and this exactly why we wanted to
introduce this no pool because if you
just specify this particular group to
use GPU and if you don't have any
workload that has a GPU that require
GPUs it can go down to 0 and once you
have it it will scale up back
two-five again yeah and there's the
other parts exactly the same we have two
notes in a no pool and note this note
has each note has one be hundred ok so
let's look into the demonstration again
so this time we're gonna go through the
demonstration of GPUs and kubernetes
engine and this time we're going to de
training or to show the power of that
activision yeah thank you Yoshi so I
want to show that it's actually really
straightforward to do whatever your she
said through the UI like and you can do
this through the command line too so I
won't take too much time but we should
want to highlight the fact that you can
create a cluster pretty quickly and you
can either attach GPUs to your cluster
directly like your default node pool
are you can like create a cluster
without GPUs and then add more node
pools which I'll show in just a bit so I
have a have a pre created cluster here
and I can go and edit this pre created
cluster and I can add node pools and
it's not just this that we another talk
later today or is it today I think I
have the side that one in okay awesome
so you should talk about that in the
stupid but where GK would automatically
create north poles for you so you don't
even have to like go manually create you
know close so for the purposes of this
demo I have created pre created a GK
cluster and I have various kinds of
locals the default one is the one that
you get when you create the cluster and
then I have a GPU pool where each node
has one GPO - so I have ten nodes and I
have ten GPUs and auto scaling is turned
on where I can scale from ten to hundred
right and I have another node pool where
each node has eight Tesla vivillon
that's attached to it and it can scale
from ten to hundred again right so I
have this dynamic pool it can scale back
to zero if I want to but for the demo
I've set it up at 10
so now that the cluster is there let's
do something interesting with it I'm
going to do something and then I'll come
back and explain what I just did
so just bear with me for a moment
and then I'll explain what exactly then
so I'm launching a few jobs here okay
just know that I'm launching lots of
jobs then each of them are taking some
amount of GPUs and I explained what is
going on so for the purposes of the demo
a typical life cycle for an ml model is
like you create some very basic
structure for your model and then you
want to explore your hyper parameters
right like you want to see what set of
hyper parameters are going to best suit
my current data or the model structure
that I come up with right so to
illustrate that I've chosen three hyper
parameters here for ResNet the same
model I've not changed the model from
like the mini cube environment to the GK
environment I've chosen my illustrative
hyper parameters to be the base starting
learning rate the bath sizes for the GPU
and the the neural net depth choices so
I have all the way from like 34 to 150 -
so what happened behind the scenes is I
used a very simple bash script you could
do something much more interesting and
the bash group essentially went through
this whole grid search across all these
different hyperparameters and it created
a cupidus job there it's it's almost
running the same command that I ran
locally right except that I'm updating
more hyper parameters than what I did
locally so it's it's the same code that
I'm running in the cloud can you show
the parameter part a little bit more so
that yeah definitely
so the parameters are learning rate the
initial learning rate and the bat sizes
that is like how many data sets you to
train on in every given moment on a GPU
and then you have depth choices just the
size of the nuances and I guess that you
already started your ml training job
with the first command that you ran
right yeah and the other thing that I
want to highlight is each job here is
each part here is using 8 GPUs right so
you're getting a DG x 1 like fox in the
cloud on-demand and you get it when you
need it and you can get rid of it when
you don't need it so it's like really
high performance compute available to
you on demand and let me highlight what
happened as part of submitting the job
right so I have
gk workloads view here what we see is we
see a whole bunch of jobs like it's like
i showed earlier i only have ten nodes
in my north pole that has eight GPUs so
ten jobs are already running right
because the nodes are already there the
rest of them are in the unscalable state
and if you go look at the cluster itself
right and if we if I just refresh this
page if I look at the cluster what we
expect to see is we expect to see more
nodes being added automatically do that
more pull and once this loads what you
see here is like there's no 32 nodes
right because I added I started 32 parts
and there were 10 nodes originally and I
know there's like 22 more nodes
automatically added to my note pool and
then in just a bit we would see that
these pods are also going to get
scheduled but what I've done is for this
demo is not wait for these jobs to
actually start start running and then
show that they're using GPUs and so on
because that's going to take quite a
while because your training is also
going to take like many many days for it
to complete even at a GPUs so what I've
done is I have free trained for a few
epochs and I'm I have tens abode loaded
up here right I have some pre trained
data and I'm loading transport here so
what I want to highlight is that with
the tens flow and with the cuba's
ecosystem you can do like really large
scale batch hyper parameter sweeps and
you can like observe all your different
hyper parameters here through tens abode
and you get this really nice like sort
of interconnected ecosystem that makes
that makes your that makes a data
scientists really really productive
that's the that's the key point that we
want to drive through this do you want
to go back to the GUI to show that to
make sure that you know your part is
also consuming oh yeah definitely so if
we drill into one of the jobs here what
we see is a job is a construct it's a
batch constructor to make sure that one
one part or X number of parts complete
based on how you configure it so if you
go in here
what you see here is like you start
seeing GPU metrics when you start seeing
GPU memory and GPU recycle these metrics
show up only if your part is actually
consuming GPUs and you see some actual
data here I don't know if it's actually
visible but it's the part is just
starting up and it's like starting to
actively use the GPUs and so you can see
those metrics there and if you go into
the logs
it'll probably show the same thing that
I showed locally except that will show
that ticket yeah I think people might
wanna see a little bit oh yeah sure I do
let's try that let's wait for the logs
load okay let's see if okay I'm having
some nice Network yeah
you have to like go to the beginning of
the training run to to look at the
initial log line okay and could just
keep going while you'll find it yeah I
can I'll probably pull it up when we get
the next time I'm switching back to the
tech yep yep okay so that's the kind of
a quick demonstration of this running
training on top of google kubernetes
engine using GPUs and literally he was
typing the command in front of me so the
training job kicked off we were quickly
in all of sudden the autoscaler kicked
in the you know you you know added the
knows that we're missing and then the
job started running as you can you know
kind of just see so that part is the
elastic part is really amazing now
training is just something in the middle
it's just only one piece and the next
step is that course of putting that in
production and you know doing running in
France so in the next in the next
demonstration you want to show the exact
same infrastructure in criminals engine
can be used for inference and prediction
in production so yeah just a second
do you want to switch thank you okay so
again I'm gonna do something and then
I'm gonna explain what I just did okay
that's done so let's go back here what I
have here in my UI is I have a serving
deployment for anyone who's familiar
with Cuban is a deployment is like the
very basic constructs for running web
services or or any sort of like that so
the deployment gives you like abilities
to do Bluebeam rollouts and I can do
like a be testing and so on so it has
lots of primitives to do like gradual
rollouts and so on and it's like a huge
ecosystem around it so what I want to
illustrate here is that you can use the
same construct and do ml inference in
production so what I have running here
is Cuba's deployment that is serving
tensorflow that's using tens flow
serving and it's serving an inception
can an inception model that show you
that model here so I have enough it's
yeah so I have the pre can inception
model that I'm and I'm and I'm serving
that right like if this there's nothing
really fancy going on here the fact that
I want highlight are the fact that you
can use pre-built tensorflow images you
don't all you have to do is bring your
model you don't have to change anything
else you can take like you can take for
example my example deployment that I
have here which is checking on github
and you can change the model and you can
get going
right I also want to highlight one more
fact not just this as what I also did in
the background which I said I'll explain
in a bit it's like I started some load
like it's not interesting if I'm just
running inference right like I have to I
have to do something with it and I want
to like simulate real-world scenario and
what I've did is like I've started
clients in the background and what the
clients are doing is they are sending
prediction requests to this tense flow
deployment that I have running here so
what would you expect when your system
gets loaded with your load generator
yeah I mean what I would expect this
my-my-my load generator to to go ahead
and like what I would ideally expect my
system to do is like I would expect the
system to automatically scale up and
then meet my load right and so I want to
see if that happens here okay that's
actually happening here so what's
happening is we saw a single part here
and Q Redis is automatically adding more
and more parts based on the demand so
what we see here is the demand was not
it's non-existent and then I started the
load then we see that the the duty cycle
of the GPUs are actually going up and
I'm using cumulus native order scaling
primitives I've already set up like auto
scaling for this dense flow deployment
here and you can reuse that too if you
want
and and I've set it up such that
whenever my duty cycle cross the
threshold add more pots and that's
exactly what we see happening here as
more pots are getting added so do I need
to build a container to kind of assert
my model maybe you already touched this
but do I need to build a container to
know you don't really have to so in fact
I can show that here so I'm going to go
ahead and change this I'm gonna change
the model that I'm serving that's all I
did right like I went tired I did this
live through edit you could do this
through like guitars or you could have
your own way of managing conflicts but
once you do that what's going to happen
is Cuba's would do a rolling deployment
so we see that version 3 is being
created here and there also health
checks embedded into the sense flow
serving container so the new the old
parts don't get removed until the new
pods are serving ready to serve
logically and that's a key point because
you can do simple rolling updates but
doing roiling updates that are safe that
doesn't drop traffic is not that easy
you know we want to stick to this screen
in fact I think when people ask us about
yeah you're doing GPU you're doing a lot
of things here what is actually the the
value that why this screen indeed
because regardless actually ml
application or not is another
application and if you're bringing those
into production you definitely do want
to have your existing version running
and then keep updating behind the scene
and that's where kubernetes is really
good at and with the GPU integration
it's all coming together so I think this
kind of shows you that how communities
and Karina's engine helps you to bring
your email application from training to
production in a very light way we didn't
even cover the hot CI CD tool chain he
just edited all in online I'm sure that
you know that's not the best way
apparently so we should definitely
include some sort of you know version
control and system into the workflow but
I want to say that you know that's the
kind of primitive that we do have on
kubernetes engines which appeals so I
introduced the GPS and communities are
ready for enterprise and if I just say
so it's I know yeah you're saying that
but we would like to share some you know
all the voices from our users Accardo
the world's largest online only grocery
retail
has been using our GPUs in coronaries
engine
they said GPUs in criminal engines are
powerful cost-effective and flexible for
their enterprise grade machine learning
we're very excited about their customers
love you know loving our product so GPU
synchronize engines are perfect for your
email application and we hopefully
highlighted the key parts of that
however machine learning as we also saw
from today's keynote it is evolving
every day really and the challenge there
is this increasing complexity increased
complexity and as a result the compute
needs what if you need more power in the
future we Google hit that problem like
five years ago if people use voice
search with speed recognition for just
three minutes a day it's like five years
ago like a long time so I'm pretty sure
with all the cool gadgets like Google
home and assistant I think this number
is too pessimistic nowadays but they
said we would need to double our data
center double order data center mean
Google the internal data center point we
said they said we got a double to me the
computation demand it's really really
like big moment and this is exactly why
we build tensor chain store processing
unit or shorten TPU today we're very
excited to announce that this cloud TPU
is incurred renée's it's now publicly
available in beta you can now use
hardware accelerator that Google design
just for machine learning at in
kubernetes engine like me like we think
but we like we have been consistent you
can access to this cloud TPU by
kubernetes api like many other resources
you don't need to manage the cloud TP by
yourself kubernetes engine will take
care of the lifecycle for you it will
also automatically scale the number of
cloud TP use when
every union and as much as you like as
far as you have the quota the
performance of cloud to you is just
unbelievable on a single cloud TPU
device with a TPU pores you can train
the the resident 50 that which has been
showing with more than 3,000 images per
second and it finishes in about nine
hours not only that with this half-size
keep you pod you can train with more
than 77 thousand images per second
honestly I'm not a person who runs
machine learning all the time or models
also all the time so this number is kind
of too large really that too hard to
kind of feel what this really kind of
means so just telling you that okay I
mentioned nine hours with a one file TPU
device this gigantic thing will you know
get the job done in 30 minutes and that
I think that's much more kind of a
tangible so with the time that you know
you reduce you know you can take a break
and go home early or more seriously I
think you can spend more time on
interesting stuff you know you can make
this cycle faster and faster
so this performance just mind-blowing
and I think I you kind of imagined
access into this cloud TPU in kubernetes
engine is very straightforward when
creating a cluster all you have to do is
to specify any dashes enable TPU we
recently introduced this feature from
1:10 so we just wanted to you know
specify or you know convey that clearly
but eventually went google kubernetes
engine always come with larger that you
know 110 you don't need this flag
anymore and we're using my alias IP
alias as a in the behind scene so we're
putting - just enable IP alias to enable
it but that's pretty much it to you for
the setup so now let's consume the cloud
GPUs - for our containers this time we
cannot use the same
example that I've been using here and
there because instead of GPUs were
requesting LTP so we have to change that
but in this case we're you really
requesting eight cloud TPU v2 cores
which is actually one cloud TPU device
from our quota and that's the change you
have to make for your prospect all right
then let's see how it's working and vish
come on again yep so how can I use a
cloud tip you from Cooper name change
it's actually very straightforward so
have a again I'm gonna board everyone
with the same model on the same pots
back that's nothing really fancy going
on this time either so I have the same
model code that I showed earlier and
we're running a slightly simpler set of
parameters here because the model is
like already set up by default to run on
GPUs because I used a model that was
already optimized 50 peers and that's
the thing that I really liked the most
with TP use is that you get this
off-the-shelf models that are already
optimized where if you're your business
case is just to apply ml to your
existing data one like make some tweaks
to your existing models it's really
straightforward you don't have to like
fiddle with anything else and you can
just get going and if you want to like
run it at scale or if you want to like
run it periodically if you want any sort
of automation on that GK makes that
really really simple so I see oh she
said I've requested a single TPU donut
here and I'm also like specified a dense
flow version 1.9 and this is something
you can do but you can choose specific
versions of times flow so that it works
what I've done in the background just to
save time is like I already went ahead
and started this job that it is shown an
order like pull up the the GK workloads
UI again so what we see here is like the
restaurant job it's aptly named brezhnev
TPU and
there's a part that belongs to this job
and if you go and look at the jobs
requirements let me pull this up you'll
see that it's asking for a single TPU
donut I'm training has already started
so you can probably look at its logs and
see that it's it's so see that training
is already going on it's processing some
sums number of samples per second I also
want to pull up tensor board so I can
pull up in support for this exact
training instance but instead what I've
done is I pulled a pencil board for an
instance that has already been pre
trained and what we see here is like you
see that with the default hyper
parameters that have been set up for a
snap you're able to process about like
your she said you're able to process
about 3,000 350 or 400 images per second
and the other cool part that I really
like about diffuse is that if you want
to scale beyond a single doughnut and if
you want to like get to larger slices
you just increase the bat size I'm not
sure for what all models it works but
for the ones that it works it's like a
really easy to use user interface that's
that's all I had about I'll keep you the
ocean thank you very much
thanks really really impressive and
powerful alrighty so I think it's time
to wrap up our kind of long journey we
introduced number of projects and
products but all of these are something
that you could start using today there's
no white list you can you know there's
no need to contact me - can I use it
everything is all available to you and
we hope this you know talk will be
awesome online very soon so that you
know we cover a law so we can read you
know go through you know Business
Administration and you know really
really get your hands dirty you know by
yourself so just to kind of recap we
introduced GPU support in mini cube
which is great for starters we talked
about GPUs and criminals which is
general with a wide range of GPUs
available and with the autoscaler
and last week we announced the cloudy PU
and kubernetes engines but besides on
all those products and features what
really wanted to you know convey today
is that containers are really great for
machine learning and I could constantly
say that from my experience inside of
Google and talking to vish and all the
great Googlers inside and kubernetes is
indeed great for such containers as well
so looking at you know going back to
this stack again but choose your
favorite ml machine learning framework
and tools pack it up into containers run
on crew readies at scale that's what I
really wanted to talk about today so
thank you for listening
[Music]
you